the Joe Rogan experience like so much of
that is realizing how little like
control we have over everything like how
we raise our children or how we interact
with people and like what does and
doesn't affect us and like the fact that
any of this works in any remote ways is
insanity yeah
it doesn't make any sense we think it
makes sense because it's normal to us
but it would really take a step back and
like think about it like this is nuts
every thought no it's this life is nuts
and you know like sitting here with yous
nuts
a year and talking about life like like
some of the people you've met through
this and like you like how did I get
here and like what is this like I feel
that way too
[ __ ] is going on what do they do to get
here like this is weird what did I do to
get here yeah I think I really believe
in some strange way that this thing made
me do this yeah that this podcast like
almost like the universe made me do this
yeah and it sounds like so pretentious
but I'm just being honest I feel like
almost like this thing has a life of its
own and a mind of its own they tricked
me
yeah they tricked me and and it played
on my obsessive mind to just keep doing
it to keep doing it maybe you get better
at this hey keep doing it bringing on
other people keep doing it keep doing it
and through this untold millions of
people been exposed yeah tell these
differently we've had three billion
downloads over the course of ten years
so I don't know how many people that is
yeah how many individuals but it's a
fuckload so all of these different
people have come on and expressed all
these different ideas and so many
different people are hearing them in
their earbuds whether in traffic or when
they're at the gym and all these ideas
percolate inside people's brains and
that it gives them different
perspectives and then it makes them
maybe explore things maybe I'm gonna try
jiu-jitsu maybe I'm gonna try yoga maybe
I'm gonna try eating better maybe I want
to try doing this and through all that
you see a shift in the culture of the
human beings there that have been in
that have been affected by all these
people's conversations yeah and for me
it feels like I just I'm getting sucked
into being here yeah like I'm like okay
and then also like me getting better at
it is just me it's like it showing me
how to extract better information and
get out of my [ __ ] way don't ruin it
and make it better for the people that
are listening it's really what it feels
like that's a note sir raised even
saying that sounds like hippy [ __ ]
well and you think about like why are we
attracted to certain things certain
people certain sometimes we're attracted
to people that does and make any [ __ ]
sense be like everything you do and say
it make me feel it's like everything
opposite of what I really want and but
but I'm attracted you and like these
yeah like like bring a certain thing out
of me
yeah develop me in a certain way and
where nobody else could do that that you
this person does that for me for some
reason or this action this sport this
thing like why am i drawn right right
right that I shouldn't be like it's
[ __ ] horrible and like it hurts and
like all these things that doesn't make
any sense at all but nothing makes any
sense at all like it doesn't make any
sense in like that I think that's why
it's so vital to follow your heart and
follow things you feel because
everything else like oh he knows what
the [ __ ] is going on like nobody can
tell you what you should do or shouldn't
do to be successful or to be happy or to
be all these things like you got it
listen to what's inside of you yeah it
means you could be wrong you could
listen to what inside inside of you and
you could be wrong but you have to learn
how to like decipher that voice better
yeah like I've been wrong about things
that I thought I wanted and yeah and
then you go okay this is why I was wrong
I was delusional or I was kidding myself
excited oh yeah yeah or I was thinking
that this thing was gonna bring me some
sort of peace so he's gonna bring me
some sort of so some sort of just
normalcy yeah you know and then it
doesn't happen so you're alright well
because there is no normalcy nothing is
normal
everything's crazy we're all nuts yeah
nobody knows what's going on all those
things that should be a t-shirt yeah
nothing is normal everything is crazy no
one knows what's going on at all
the sooner we realize that the better
would be like we're all in the loony
loony yeah yeah it'll definitely be
easier that's why I'm I'm always scared
of drugs that make people confident my
favorite drugs marijuana cuz it does the
opposite of making me confident
mm-hm it makes me paranoid it makes me
it makes me compassionate and it makes
me also like : jeez this is crazy
yeah like that's why I like it yeah I
like it because I think the drugs that
make you colicky we should all be a
little less confident yeah you know we
need each other a lot more than we like
to pretend and this life is like this
temporary thing that we're going through
we have a certain amount of heartbeats
and then who knows yeah the lights go
out and hopefully we go to a better
place but yeah well I think the thing it
does to is it strips that that veil away
like that veil of feeling like
everything's in balance and normal and
you know life is like this is life like
life is [ __ ] weird man we're super
weird super we distract ourselves with
normalcy and habits but take a step back
and like this is nuts this is all nuts
and we pretend like it's normal and it's
cool and everyone's like in agreeance
that like we all know what's going on
no [ __ ] going on we're all living in a
spaceship flying through the atmosphere
yeah we're all tripping balls over here
we're just all doing it so it feels
normal but we can find some moments of
comfort and happiness in the chaos and
that's what we're we're all seeking yeah
you know we're all seeking these moments
of comfort and happiness and camaraderie
and and friendship you know we're all
seeking love - we're all seeking the
good feelings you know but you got to
get through the shitty ones to even
appreciate the good feelings it's a
catch-22 yeah yeah but just understand
that you need any good in the bad no you
don't know what good is unless you have
bad yeah it has to be that way
[Applause]